what to do when your tax base flees your
city
if you're the left-wing lurch you
promise to tax whoever stays
more you really want to change things in
this city
then everyone better change a lot of the
way we live
more foundationally if you just talk
about it and feel self-satisfied god
bless you
that's not actually going to change
things what changes things is
redistribution of wealth
tax the wealthy at a much higher level
and i just feel like this is a lot of
cocktail party comfort going on rather
than people honestly dealing with this
issue help me tax the wealthy help me
redistribute wealth
help me build affordable housing in
white communities
if you want desegregation
this is what happens when you elect a
commie who can't do math not only do
they spread deadly beliefs
they can't even pay for them it's the
downward spiral of leftism dragging
everyone down with it
and here's how it's done one take over a
city that was kicking butt thanks to
republicans
two reverse policies that created the
success and enact those that foster
disaster
three funnel the money to pet projects
instead of improving quality of life
four very important vilify police which
drives early retirements way up and
recruitment
way down five drive out investment due
to uncertainty
fear and regulation six when people
leave tax who's ever dumb enough to
still be here
me watch the tax base operate
bonus points do this during a pandemic
so
i gotta ask why are we still here i
don't understand it
when city leaders can't protect us as
stores are looted and burned and then
they deny reality
afterwards i did a one minute search
thousands
of articles with statistics showing
sharp persistent increases
in violent crime but in nyc alone
murders up 34
shootings 87 burglaries 43
and people are home i could cite
specifics
children shot dead mad men attacking
people with bricks and spears
and attempted daytime rape in a safe
subway
spot i could go on but who's listening
not the dems or their mouthpieces who
mocked
this misery democratic cities are
in chaos right now is this what you want
from joe biden
and they're going to take your country
away and they're taking down the statues
and
crime is rising oh my gosh
it's so bad and they get defunding
police it's like
now six weeks later how their tune has
changed
i think democrats are ignoring this
problem or hoping that it will go away
joe biden may be afraid to do it i'm not
sure maybe he won't
maybe he is he's got to address it
what's happening now is happening under
donald trump's watch
the rioting has to stop chris as you
know and i know
it's showing up in the polling it's
showing up in focus groups
it is the only thing right now
that is sticking
wow that's amnesia my how things change
though when it impacts them politically
which is why the only way to make them
care is to call them out
then throw the politicians out or leave
for saner parts tennessee idaho wyoming
just don't bring your left wing bs with
you part of america
still needs to function
so uh emily it's as if
mayor de blasio is inventing new ways to
be the worst mayor
ever it's like he thinks no if i'm going
to go out
in a in a blast i'm going to make myself
really look look look awful
right like we can he's running out of
ideas
i will say that the fiscal rot in new
york city
runs deep we know that that city sees
residence income
as its own income and the city itself
has
an income tax right in addition to the
state from which they collect
over 11 billion dollars and every dollar
of that goes toward
covering the about 80 000 city employees
payroll
every dollar of that and don't forget
about the open the books expose where we
all learned that the city spends over 2
billion
a year on overtime so that city is a
rotting cesspool and we don't need
that ridiculous mayor to continue to
show us i'll say one word really quickly
on the moving element though because i
already moved
from california and it breaks my heart
to see that state continue to crumble
if you're given the choice or an
opportunity to actually exercise
sovereignty and a choice over your tax
dollars and how they're spent
or the health of your community like
investing in law enforcement and safety
and free speech and property and all of
those things we hold dear
damn right you're going to exercise it
and absolutely i would move
yeah dan you are from new york uh is it
ever going to come back
are you an optimist or a pessimist no
i'm a pessimist
always sorry i just don't have any faith
in humanity left at all
i love you guys though and ladies you're
great
having said that well here's why though
greg i actually have a reason for this
you know liberals are just immune to
facts it's like at an early age they get
like a vaccine and facts just can't
penetrate or something right
it's not like we haven't tried economic
redistribution of millionaires tax
before
i took a few notes france tried it
remember that 75 percent tax yeah 10 000
people fled the country one year 12 000
next
my home state of maryland where i used
to have tried that too um the
millionaires tax cost the state
cost for liberals that means they lost
money um 1.7 billion dollars 31 000
people left
um we've tried this stuff but what's
particularly infuriating about this and
this is my message to the republican
party
and everyone else i don't know you squat
okay
so the liberals out there let me just be
crystal clear and i wish a party
candidate would get up and say
i don't owe you a damn thing i owe you
to pay for the constitutional role of
government because i live here too
but i don't know you squat i don't owe
you my money you're not entitled to my
money
if you are an able-bodied human being
with two legs functioning organs and a
body
get off your caboose remove your rump
from the chair and go to work
get a job i don't owe you anything
nobody owes you anything
the world doesn't owe you anything and i
just wish the republican party would
stand up against this stupid
redistribution our argument and say
we're not
helping here people need to work that's
what makes them better off
well i will say this i'm glad that book
overcoming shyness that i lent you has
really worked
yes it worked really well that was a big
problem
i guess hey so one one can't
can't progressives and socialists admit
that for them to ha
to indulge their dreams they need
capitalists and if you keep driving
capitalists out you're going to run out
of the money there's a dog barking
sorry first time in the whole pandemic
first time in the whole pandemic
it's okay it's okay i'm gonna share time
with jasper dana
i'm i'm a jasper fan but uh but greg
i i think i think differently about this
than you and dan because
i think populist on the left and the
right think that
these big companies that wall street
really took advantage of the little guy
especially after 2009 and that you know
too big to fail and these companies and
executives getting these exorbitant
golden parachutes and the like that it's
not fair to the average
working american who saw their salaries
uh you know stagnate so that's one
argument but let me just say
much more broadly about new york city
you know i'm from new york
i love new york and i think anybody who
says oh new york
is going down the tubes i'll take that
bet
i take that bet now and people took that
bet in the 70s when said
oh there's economic problems in new york
remember ford to
new york city dropped dead then after 9
11 people said oh new york's never
coming back
you know what it's like betting against
the stock market the stock market may
have a dip
but long term the stock market goes up
and new york
is going to go up again that's because
it's not run by liberals
well and i thought
giuliani i was going to say that i i
yeah
one for complimenting giuliani
right now and giuliani want to return
your
guy that might be it might be something
that those two wanted to get to return
but i think you have to look to the next
generation
that would come in and try to figure out
a way to do it right i do want to tell
you this though
um i don't know if new york will try
this but listen to something that
california is floating
they have so many people leaving that
what they've decided to do
is to go back and tax previous earnings
so previous earnings and your
accumulated wealth
from before you left so
this truly is hotel california you can
check in
but now apparently you can't leave even
if you have a u-haul
um yes i think you need to re-record
that eagles classic dana
and uh and incorporate the facts you
just mentioned